hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast
this is are you garbage it's a show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow up classy
or if there's a big old piece of trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day
i'm down here at aunt toddy's basement i
got my new heart medication in me
i know i gotta hide it around the house
she's like a [ __ ]
truffle pig it's like a bloodhound i
tell you she'll be boofing
in no time she sees a cvs receipt all of
a sudden she's all over you
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me uh he refers to me as a guy
he works with
i tell people he's my best pal he's a
ceo of ru garbage he's really an
international businessman
when you get down to it why is that oh
you have your foot in a couple of things
you like to dabble
cars don't even ship to canada i'm not
that international
sorry about that apparently they still
haven't shipped anywhere they're right
next to us
they'll be coming soon they'll be coming
around the mountain when they come
gang give it up for mr kippy kevin james
ryan god damn it hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in calling his name
as always please make sure you rate if
you subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and you know what
about those numbers
true to root true to [ __ ] roof also
patreon.com
are you garbage uh you can sign up to
get bonus content you get bonus episodes
of ayg
episodes of hard feelings which is me
and foley [ __ ] chopping it up the
real
deal the bread and butter uh and then we
do a live stream every month with the
top tier patrons you can get involved in
that it's a good [ __ ] time yes we do
thank you so much guys and we love you
and how about a nice big shout out to
our producer extraordinaire
he's got his mic back this week he's
mic'd up he's out of the penalty box
we'll see how he does he's like tom
brady in mid game with the mic
on let's go he's the pride of the
chicago comedy scene
give it up for t-bone toby mcmuffin
what uh welcome back oh it feels good to
be back you know finally a part of
something successful my life is falling
apart
[Laughter]
like diane keaton over there huh i don't
know um
yeah me neither uh like joan rivers huh
huh gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with us today
he is a very funny comedian and actor
you have seen him on gotham comedy live
conan uproarious this is not happening
on comedy central
sex fails the late late show he also has
a brand new podcast that's about to come
out called terrible therapists
with fellow comedians matt wayne and
gary veeder
not to mention he's got his own album
out called barely regal
but the big question about his mind
today is he garbage
now he walked in here looking like he
knows how to fix the chassis on a 72
chevy yeah he's a good looking kid kids
got grease written all over them
all right and i feel it give it up for
mr doug smith everybody
what's up guys thank you so much for
having me look at him with a stash
piercing blues man i can't even look
over there i'm gonna look at t-bone
where i feel comfortable looks like he
should have died on the air
under the table thanks for coming by
good looking world war ii guy face
i'm an ally i promise yeah you do look
like you'd be
black and white and just like really
good
yeah do you smoke
uh no no no no you'd be a he would be
like
well who would philip morris would want
on an ad oh yeah i'm leaning against the
pickup truck yeah he's got the pack of
bernies in the arm
you put a [ __ ] put an army helmet on
him in front of some palm trees in iwo
jima
with a [ __ ] marlboro sticking out of
his mouth that's a life magazine picture
of the year right there
move a couple of units get this guy to
times square to be [ __ ] cleaning up
um what is the origin story of doug's of
doug smith you had said you came in
that you were a connecticut guy you're a
suburban guy i am yeah i grew up in
ridgefield connecticut
about 50 miles north of here
connecticut's a little dicey
it is a connecticut bougie reputation
so fairfield county is where i grew up
fairfield county
is i don't know if it still is it was at
one time like the wealthiest county in
the united states
solely because of a few towns you got
greenwich shore
new canaan sure uh darien
you got a few towns that are really
bourgeoisie a little bit of cash
ridgefield is is a kind of a bougie town
but then you know you got like
bridgeport you got i've been up
i've done fairfield and it ain't that
nice yeah yeah the gas stations are
weird up there
new haven hartford most of connecticut
is a
complete [ __ ] lastly lottery drive
up to 95.
take any exit and you'll see well off
coming from philly like connecticut we
always thought like it's that reputation
a lot of cash boat shoes yachts whatever
all right but then we went up we went up
to do a show up there i was like yo we
are not
in connecticut yeah yeah no my my
hometown
everybody looks like they just stepped
out of an llb catalog you know oh really
everyone drives a jeep cherokee everyone
has a golden retriever nice
abercrombie yeah yeah yeah yeah
little old money uh-huh nice what'd your
parents do growing up
uh my mom was a stay-at-home mom my dad
worked for the same
local insurance company for 40 years
aj carnell insurance shout out aj
[Laughter]
sold life insurance and was able to keep
your mom home
in ridgefield yep he had to do pretty
good he did he didn't look like ed
ryerson you know
growing up ned ryerson
from groundhog day remember when he
meets him he was selling his own life
insurance
yeah um growing up i always thought my
dad
did better than he did i remember when i
finally found out what my dad pulled in
a year i was very disappointed
he bought the house off a grandma what
the [ __ ]
well actually yeah both both my parents
both my parents grew up wealthy but they
and then they inherited some land so my
dad inherited
five acres of property right next to the
house that he grew up on
damn so we had like we had like not a
huge house we had five and a half acres
of property
that's pretty any time we've talked
about this anytime the property lines
touch another relative it's a little
[ __ ] dicey yeah
it's kind of a it's kind of a trash move
to get the land and be like i'm just
gonna live right here
well no what happened was i'm sure his
grandparents
bought land and then bought the lot next
to them
yeah right yeah hey there will be blood
i understand what's going on what the
[ __ ] i'm trying to make a joke here
you're like no actually well it was a
plot and a half builders hey shut up
well they probably broke it off how many
brothers and sisters your dad had
uh he had two brothers so they probably
got broken off something too they got
something too yeah there's no it was
like a compound you were all
you were all right there wait those
hillbillies in
other in other surround towns in the
surrounding area so they got they each
got a plot
elsewhere and my dad died i think my dad
got the shitty deal now that i think of
it right yeah had to live next to us
with his family
ronnie we got something special for you
the other two probably didn't even take
the land they're probably living in
their basement
wait so is that house so then he built
the house on that land yeah and that's
where you were born and raised
correct with your grandparents next door
they both died before i was born
but otherwise that would have been trash
that probably rubbed them out
[ __ ] no neighbors daddy oh let's go
life insurance is slow i need another
five
yeah yeah right five acres
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] so they were they passed on
yeah so my
siblings all my siblings are uh are much
older than me
oh you're one of those kids
my siblings aren't they're how many jeep
cherokees right this gets trashed
well hold on before you get to that i
wanted to ask you do you think you're
garbage
i am a hundred percent certain i am here
all right um so my siblings are
14 16 and 18 years older than me what
the
[ __ ] same same parents same parents yeah
holy [ __ ] i got i got a i got a brother
that's 16 years younger than me but it's
a different mom i can at least say that
yeah one of my one of my first jokes
when i started doing stand-up
was about how old my mom is and i i
would be like my mom is uh
my mom was 47 when she gave birth to me
which is pretty crazy
considering the odds of having a child
that late in life you know birth defects
is
slim to none and as far as i know i'm
the only person in history
to have ever made a full recovery from
down syndrome
talk about a bounce back you can't turn
it around on the back nine
it's good he's nice all right it's weird
yeah holy [ __ ]
47 47 and my dad was 51.
yeah was it clearly an accident yeah
intentional
no no so my uh uh what the [ __ ] cheryl
his [ __ ] scream i gotta go back to
work i only got five acres what's the
[ __ ]
menopauses horseshit um damn
yeah apparently before women go into
menopause they have like one last day
yeah yeah so uh what the [ __ ]
sounded right they got me fired up huge
mistake
um so yeah the way they the way they
told my siblings
was uh so i grew up with a with a pool
in-ground pool
not garbage um everything else is
garbage
we had an in-ground so uh we had a pool
and the way my mom told
my sister also if you have five acres
and no pool there's
i mean what the [ __ ] are we [ __ ] up
that pool should be absolutely
fine dude i was always freaked out when
i
got invited to like barbecues or
something like that where there wasn't a
pool in the summer
right he was outside sweating yeah it's
like what the [ __ ] i could do this at
home yeah
spray you with the hoses yeah [ __ ] break
the sprinkler out or something
somebody got a water balloon or
something i'm [ __ ] just fencing over
here
jesus christ no pull get out of here
i'm not coming in the winter
[ __ ] that so so we had a pool and the
way the way they broke into my siblings
was it was they uh
they said we're going to have a little
one running around soon
so we got to build a fence around the
pool and my
siblings went you know through the
rolodex every family friend of who could
be pregnant
but i always thought it was hilarious
that like the three of them
their entire childhood they weren't good
enough to have that defensiveness yeah
that's true
if you fall in who gives a [ __ ] but this
this new jack we gotta keep him safe
holy keep an eye on this kid yeah that's
pretty banana damn dude
yeah so he's got they just did it one
night and
they did it one night and yeah so i
basically kind of details are you
looking for here
what was she wearing who asked that
just one night he went to pound town huh
god damn it foley
gave her a good deal on his premium huh
am i right
holy [ __ ] all right so they had to land
so he had but he had a nice business he
worked he did well
you said you found out what it was he
did okay he did okay i found
i found out later he he only pulled in
like 80 grand a year which is not
you know for for connecticut for
connecticut stay at home
a stay at home five acres of four kids
yeah um so yeah he worked my dad
my my mom stayed at home and uh this is
when you were a kid too
yeah so he's 50 he has you right so
let's say you're 9
10 years old he's in the six so you had
the old dad
i did have the old daddy and the other
ones they were [ __ ] what vietnam where
the [ __ ] they were your brothers and
sisters they were they were going right
they were out in the dust bowl or
something
so it was just you pretty much yeah my
my sister who's the one closest in age
to me she was she was around for
up until i was like five or so but yeah
that's pretty much all out of the
picture
so for all intents and purposes grew up
an only child
did you ever wonder like why are they so
much older than me
um yeah i mean that it was all
intentional they were all they were they
were all two years apart that was
strategic
yeah and then that was yeah um a little
curveball
have you ever did anybody ever mistake
your dad for like your grandfather is
there anything oh all the time
all the time they'd come pick me up from
school dug your grandma's here
you shut your mouth she still got it
yeah my my dad was a was a trooper but
you know like you're right by the time i
was
by the time i was i must have been
exhausted
yeah so we'd go out and have a catch 10
minutes in and be like oh dog my [ __ ]
shoulder man
i gotta go inside well when i first
became friends with hitler we were like
i i guess it was probably one [ __ ]
that's it
goddamn rotator cuff he would give me i
i realized that we me and him because
he's 10 years older than me but like
i'd be like yo let's go here well let's
go grab beers or something he would used
to give me excuses that my dad used to
give me like he'd like
he used to hit me with as a friend i'm
just gonna lay down and rest my eyes a
little bit
[Laughter]
let me just lay here and rest my eyes
i'm like dude you sound like my dad
trying to go like when i asked to go to
chuck e cheese
foley has never once silently stood up
yeah no
no he plugs the lights in behind the
[ __ ] shelves and
he wheezes for 20 minutes sounds like an
old [ __ ] dialogue modem
yeah i feel you man i tell you after 35
you start to really feel it
i don't know what i'm going to do if i
have kids get a nanny or something like
that
didn't have to take a darkness yeah i
don't know how to break it take a big
don't do it man
my dad would you he would use his age
against me all the time oh like yeah
he'd be out shoveling
you know and i'd be like looking through
the window sure what are you doing why
aren't you out here doing this i could
have a [ __ ] heart attack
you had a good run you know well think
about how you got it you have a kid
right i do
think about how tired you get yeah and
then imagine tacking on [ __ ] 30 years
today
how old are you now 38 and how old you
your your
your child five he's five you had him
when you were 32. that's that's even
still
that would be that math was wrong i
wasn't 33.
all right relax well who does the math
and then gets it wrong
ken jennings over here take it easy we
are having a good time like the double
down you've been all over me since we
started
hey that's my stick what do you want
from me that's all i got
today lean into it but still that's a
little bit old well not really to for
today
but 33 yeah i mean 33 in new york
you might as well be 19 yeah sure that's
true yeah
right right but now at 38 i'm sure you
feel chasing him around
yeah sure sure um so
uh juicy tidbit though i was i was
raised a
jehovah's witness what yeah
so this are getting weirder by the
minute geez
so you get you guys both grow up outside
philly right yeah yeah yeah so i'm sure
you're
familiar did you ever have them come to
your door anymore no never really no not
in my neighborhood
no [ __ ] yeah i had them in philly they
knocked on the door one time
and we were in the middle of when i was
at temple in north philly and they
knocked on the door and
i was like yeah i'm like get in here
you're gonna get hurt what are you doing
up there
[ __ ] walking around just like that
for and they came in they sat down
and they were nice they were like two
kids like my age or whatever but
right uh yeah that's the only time ever
really yeah wow
i think a pair of them one time made it
to the driveway
and my mom was [ __ ] halfway at the
door wow
now out there with them now now would
you have to go around
yup wait a minute oh my god wait how
does this happen
were they always jehovah's witness yeah
so uh
my mom was one of the few people few
success stories
of someone that was successfully flipped
from
people going around door to door so when
she married my dad was in the marines
talked to they brought in anything
[Laughter]
so they were uh oh my god they were
married
they were living uh they were living um
in ridgefield they got out of the
marines they were living in ridgefield
and someone came around knocked on the
door
she let them in started a bible study
with them
and within a year she was
she was flipped wait you weren't born
yet i wasn't born yet no
so they didn't have any kids yet so this
whole wow
so she went full bore into this thing
and
uh raised all my siblings that way
you're i'm sorry what was your where was
your dad in this was he
he on the fence yeah i feel like you
gotta be close
to the edge before you get put like what
was it what
was the original oh an army couldn't
walk in and turn him you know what i
mean like
you would need all you would need a lot
it'd have to be a pretty nice sandwich
tray i'll tell you that
who's gator in this thing so they were
they were already religious
or they were uh my dad grew up
protestant
and my mom grew up episcopalian okay
that makes sense
but not not super nice right down the
middle right yeah yeah
um so he turned two not until i was
12 years old so jehovah's witnesses as
you know catholics get baptized when
their babies jehovah's witness is you
choose when you get baptized
so i i got baptized when i was 16.
that's why i think they had the pool
yeah
anytime you're ready so um yeah he was
on the fence
he he just kind of went along with it
the whole time i was
growing up so she was really really into
it
um and it's it's uh
i don't want to say it's as quite as
intense as hasidic judaism but it's not
a far cry 4 extremely insular
sort of like bubble they have the
watchtower over in brooklyn right
they did they just sold they sold all
that property and made
whole tons of money you know what i'm
talking about if you're going over the
brooklyn bridge there's this huge
building like
huge building and it says the watchtower
on it
and that was like the jehovah's witness
world headquarters for a long time yeah
they lived there they did all this kind
of stuff it's basically
like a commune and they have they have
three of them so they have one
in patterson new york uh wall kill new
york and they had the
the brooklyn one they just sold all that
property it wasn't just one building
they had multiple
city blocks in dumbo that they bought up
in like the early 80s
that's a little bit of cash right there
that's gonna be turned into something
nice
so they sold those buildings and then
they just moved their world headquarters
to warwick new york okay and have an
even
bigger compound there now do you guys
get a piece of that you get a couple
acres out of that
how's that work yeah you're old man
they're me
a little bit
you're out i'm out yeah yeah what does
that mean you left it you don't like run
away in the middle of the night like
barefoot you just stopped going to
church
right yeah so i you know my whole
my whole life i was i was in it because
my mom was
she wasn't like a casual member she was
really in it and it's
and it's what's what's it so it's like
church a couple times a week no caffeine
or whatever we were just we were just
talking about leaving before after
communion was over not even wait till
the end of mass
we got a [ __ ] pizza waiting to
palermos we're out [ __ ] keep it real
casual so what like what
what did a week look like so i don't
know anything about okay
yup so did you wear the shirt the white
shirt with the black tie
the best is just hearing people's
preconceived notions
a bunch of idiots no pre-marital sex
live
chickens were you in the blues brothers
did you get baptized in like a pond or
something i got baptized in an
above-ground pool
really what the [ __ ] at the new haven
coliseum
pull the plunge at the new haven college
they have an above ground pool at the
new haven coliseum
yeah yeah also all the money these
[ __ ] jehovah's witness have all this
land and dumbo you can't get it
you can't get an in-ground pool to get
done [ __ ] yeah baptize me in the [ __ ]
east river yeah do something
you got to bring your own water bring my
own water i
got baptized in the dunk tank at the
county fair
getting a curveball on them though i'll
tell you that put me right back
one shot of people waiting they get
baptized
all wearing short sleeve white collared
shirts guys
these nerds can't hit anything gang i
don't know about you but when something
breaks over at my house i fix it i don't
care if that's a clog in the sink if i
backed up the toilet
if i got a squeaky door or squeaky wheel
i don't know but i'm on top of it
but a place a lot of us let that go is
in the bedroom yeah
if something's not right do yourself a
favor
and fix it yeah it can be a little bit
embarrassing but if you go to roman.com
garbage right now we can take care of it
for you baby
with roman you get an online evaluation
for
free and ongoing care for e.d with all
the comfort and privacy of your home you
know you don't got to go sit in some
weird office or anything it's all done
from the couch you don't even need pants
on to be doing this that's right
uh you'll get a u.s licensed healthcare
professional will work with you
to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships right
to your door privately two-day shipping
baby
really two days wow whole process real
straightforward
easy to do and discreet nobody's talking
the neighbors don't know
nobody sees you coming and going it's
easy peasy just our little secret
gets getting started is simple just go
to getroman.com
garbage and complete the online visit uh
take care of your ed without ever
leaving your home
complete an online visit today and
connect with a health care professional
to get it
taken care of why put it off the world's
a crazy place
you you know you get there's one thing
you can fix it's this that's right
trust roman get the roman.com garbage
um and you'll save 15 off your first
month with our promo code getroman.com
garbage it's really time to take care of
your ed and remember get started today
you'll save 15 bucks off your first
order of ed treatment let's face it gang
going to the post office is no fun and
no fun at all
that's why we here at ru garbage
recommend you mailing and shipping
online with stamps.com
oh yes stamps.com allows you to mail and
ship anytime anywhere right from your
computer
you can send letters you can ship
packages and you can pay a lot less than
you would at usps
or ups and more all right stamps.com has
saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons and tons of
money
with stamps.com you get the same service
as the post office
or ups but all in one place you don't
got to go anywhere
plus big discounts on mailing and
shipping rates yeah guys if you got a
small business stamps.com is the way to
go it's easy
peasy you print postage from your house
from your office from your car wherever
you got a computer and printer
you can get it done we use it we send
out our merch with it
it's so easy an idiot could do it so go
check it out stance.com it's a
no-brainer saving you time and money
there's millions of millions of small
businesses all over the country doing it
get involved with them
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
garbage you'll get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial
nice plus repostage and a digital scale
not bad we got one
we got one in the mail the other day
it's perfect go so just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in garbage
at stamps.com promo code garbage
stamps.com
never go to the post office again real
quick gang want to talk to you about the
good time
uncle hank and the kipster having there
on the stereo app
every thursday night at nine o'clock
we're chopping it up with you
folks yeah it's a little bit of an after
party the free episode comes out on
itunes spotify you get that and then
this is the after party you can come
we're answering your questions
live on the live stream you record them
you send them in to us we
we play them we answer them we make
funny or we make supervised
i have a couple of beers it's a good
time baby go to stereo dot com
slash kevin ryan or slash h foley the
link will be in the description
we get to wet our beaks a little bit
free to download easy peasy
see you there now back to the show um
all right so what's a wee i got it
what's like a week so a week
a week is uh so sunday
you would have uh uh two meetings
and they're back to back so you can you
know it's like once an hour and a half
the next one's an hour and a half so
it's basically you're eating
like pitching what's going on here it's
like a church service oh so they they
don't call it a church it's a kingdom
hall
so i went to a kingdom hall it sounds
pretty classy though lewisborough new
york it was a justice league right over
the border
yeah right sit next to the green lane
i'm sorry this is terrible we're having
a good time here
okay so sunday morning was uh you know
three hour church service and then we
would have to go out knocking on doors
after that for another two hours so
sunday was [ __ ]
all in that same neighborhood sunday
monday you know
who who do i know like people in your
neighborhood i would assume where are
you knocking
uh so you get like a territory map so
like
so like my congregation had people
like had like five towns so we would we
would go knocking on doors in ridgefield
new canaan
lewisburg where i grew up in connecticut
was right on the border of new york
state so westchester's right over the
border there you go
so there was like five different towns
that we would get like a territory map
you know like a one or two mile radius
and you basically just hit
every [ __ ] house in that territory
map and then
if somebody's home and they are
into it which is very rare you know you
keep going back
your your goal is to is to flip them so
you know you're you're basically
processing
a lot of manpower for not a lot of
results yeah who would go out there so
you do the two meetings on sunday
who's driving you and what age do you
get to start knocking on doors i was i
was going out
knocking on door with with you know my
parents from the time i was six years
old
so not even not even saying
and holding out a pamphlet and no one's
going to slam a door on us
please my kid's [ __ ] up he needs your
help just join the [ __ ] church will
you
throw him a [ __ ] bone when did they
let you start leading the pitch when you
when when you when did you get to become
the jerry maguire
who's coming with me
[Laughter]
help me help you [ __ ]
it's i'm baffled did you ever get
anybody
i never i never got anybody i had i had
a few people that
i think took pity on me and would you
know extend the conversation or
something
yeah exactly you were never by yourself
right uh
no you get so you get you get broken up
into car groups usually of like four or
five people
and you just drive around you know as a
kid you're stuck in the [ __ ] back
seat
you know between two other bible
thumpers and you're just you know
driving around door to door
would they hit a mickey d's or something
like that oh yeah that was the only
saving grace would you have
i knew it had to be something a coffee
break at around 11 a.m
it's like amway scientology yeah holy
fully would definitely fall for it if
you're like hey listen you'll get you'll
get a new shirt
and we'll go for a walk and we'll stop
at mcdonald's the scientologist almost
got me and my buddy shriner out in uh
out in seattle one time
dude that we were this close i was
sometimes i started shaving my head
i was [ __ ] in they sent some [ __ ]
dime piece in
if your name is shriner you might as
well have a target on your back right
yeah jesus they sent some smoke show in
and all so i don't know what she was
saying
i was [ __ ] like yeah let's do it okay
here we go
he's ready to grab the things and do it
but nobody wants to hear this [ __ ] so
basically what you're doing is you're
going around and you're telling people
they they call it spreading the good
news so they think that they have a
positive message but it's like fire
what you're basically telling people is
you need to become a jehovah's witness
you need to become a faithful servant of
jehovah or when armageddon comes
which they have been telling people for
the better part of a century is around
the [ __ ] corner
when armageddon comes perspective
when armageddon comes you are you're
doomed so that's that's basically the
message that you're telling people when
you knock on their door
so nobody wants nobody wants to hear
that sunday and you're knocking on door
early dude like you would start i got
the game what are you doing
like nine kids back again
close the blind i got a nickel and a
giants i gotta deal with this game with
a
mustache
let's go so i grew up near clearwater
which is the headquarters for
scientology and we call them all sinos
yeah is there did were there any names
thrown your way specific for jehovah's
witness like jovi's oh yeah was anybody
like
was anybody mean to you like get the
[ __ ] out of here you're gonna burn in
hell
i mean i remember being 12
when somebody threatened to pull a gun
on me and this was
enriched as like a bougie town and i i
got through my whole spiel like hey
we're doing a bible-based volunteer work
this morning
spreading the good news of jehovah
and the guy was like i'm going to give
you two minutes to get this car out of
my driveway or i'm getting my shotgun
and i was like gotcha
two minutes is pretty good yeah i just
picture the guy inside like
fumbling shells and [ __ ] trying honey
the starter is working on the car i'm
just taunting him standing right at the
end of the driveway
you're like 90. i do want his mailbox
not touching you not touching you holy
[ __ ] i had people i had uh somebody
released their
basically sick their german shepherd on
me once and i had a sprint to the car to
get away from
those dude those dogs are they scare me
now were you giving the full court press
or is it like
because i think i think i do remember
once and it was and it was
no we're not interested and that was it
they walked away right did you have
people that were like oh dude they could
they coach you in terms of overcoming
every kind of rejection take a script
yeah if somebody says they're jewish you
got a line for that if somebody says
they're not interested
not everybody's perfect
[Laughter]
well you folks have a good time in hell
really i don't even see your horns
[Laughter]
so there's a lot there's a line for
everything um oh what did they tell you
you're jewish
i don't even [ __ ] remember dude like
i was you start talking jewish hello
yeah shabbat shalom make them think
they're one of you
turn your hat on backwards um
but yeah it's just it's constant
rejection
but you're prepared you're prepared for
everything that they throw out of it
prepare you for stand-up comedy huh
oh yeah probably absolutely blowing
through it but i you know i hated
going around knocking on doors obviously
so i i had a 12 year old kid
i had [ __ ] to be a paper boy right
yeah so i had a system
when i was able to like i was never like
in a car driving around house to house
on my own because i would never do that
it was always you know
obligatory but when i was in a car group
when i was like a teenager i would be
able to you know get out of the car go
up to the house by myself give a knock
or ring the doorbell
and my move was if you know if this
bottle caps the doorbell
i just put my finger right next to the
doorbell you know
or if you knock you know you just hover
your your knuckles right above the
kid and it's like no one's home you know
look at you working from the inside
yeah yeah if they answer the door he's
like listen i don't want anything
i just have to act like i'm talking to
you just nod your hair
take the paper and then close the door
can you shake it
down so when did you sit now
the reason i was asking you this is wild
it's [ __ ] bananas
[Laughter]
i like a fair fight two minutes
you got two seconds to get the [ __ ]
anything so this is going to be
you i'm going to give you 45 minutes to
get the hell out of here but once we get
in the question it's going to be unique
what were the rule or the rules of like
that the household had to be like you
said you know were you
allowed to have certain things not
certain things in the household have you
ever seen the a team
i haven't i know i know of it but i've
never seen it
um so basically
it's it's a bible-based religion
and they they old testament or new
testament both it's a combination
so it's they use a bible called the the
new world translation of the holy
scriptures
so all their new testament i have that
album i like the earlier stuff it's a
double too many skits
an intro and outro wasn't pete holmes in
that
wow all right so so it's they take the
bible
at face value so like so
no it's it's entirely based on
restrictions so no holidays
at all growing up no christmas no
birthdays
not even my own birthday no halloween no
thanksgiving i was going to ask you if
you ever had a henna tattoo
i'll take that as a no wait now we know
how your old man afforded the house and
lived in a nice neighborhood
he never had to drop anything on [ __ ]
christmas presents or nothing
they could think of how much they say is
the jehovah's witnesses think about what
they saved on halloween
holy [ __ ] yeah so i was one of the
i was one of the few kids in my
congregation that was
allowed to go to public school and it's
not because my
parents thought i should it's because
they were too [ __ ] old and lazy to
want to do the homeschooling thing
but a lot of kids like your brothers
were your brothers and sisters
homeschooled
they weren't no they also went to public
school but a lot of my friends growing
up were
were homeschooled because it's all about
keeping you
from escaping worldly worldly
wait wasn't there like a jehovah's
witness school there wasn't like a
catholic school nope
nope it's all homes think there would be
yeah damn [ __ ] that
so they want to keep you from you know
being exposed any
outside influence you know were you
allowed to do what if you wanted to go
over
that that was the thing i was i wanted
to ask you about the going around
door-to-door yeah wouldn't you knock on
somebody's door and they'd be like
[ __ ]
dougie what are you doing here yeah what
are you [ __ ] at my house that's
that's the thing so like i
you know i grew up in ridgefield we had
territories in five different towns
so i would pray every time that we
weren't we
wouldn't be going around knocking on
doors in richmond some hot chick from
high school
exactly yeah yeah yeah and it would and
it would happen something happens
they're like what are you doing here and
you're like i'm a registered sex
offender
i thought this was tommy's house i'll
see you now i'll see you in trigonometry
on monday
truth is i was looking around here
aluminum siding and uh hey you don't
want to get stuck out in the rain with
that i'll tell you
i used to sell roofs and siding in the
windows door-to-door i thought that was
bad
yeah this is tough out of my don't knock
on [ __ ]
foley's door i'm thinking that so most
most
kids honestly felt bad for me i really
didn't get mad
there was one kid who was an [ __ ] who
was on my bus and i wound up knocking on
his door
and i knew and i knew that it was his
hat because he was on my bus route and
so we were driving around
his neighborhood one day and it was you
know you go like every other it's like
round robin and then you didn't tell
your mom
look it's [ __ ] nicki's house i don't
want to go knocking on the door i did
and she was like what what are you
ashamed why are you ashamed you have an
opportunity to tell him
something that could save his life you
know that was her philosophy
you're doing him a favor by saving him
from armageddon
oh so i had to go to this
holy [ __ ] man
[Laughter]
cbd came out 20 years too late
that's [ __ ] dreams smokeable cbd
for when the armageddon arrives chick
needs a chai tea and an eddy
five milligrams holy
[ __ ] yeah you know i
i remember the walk up to his door just
being like god i hope he's just waiting
for you yes man he's got the bat
he answers the door what the [ __ ] are
you doing
i was like
cow was out of the bag i owe you what's
going on yeah i thought the eagle's
covered
oh man that's so [ __ ]
so he called me jehovah boy for the rest
of which uh
that's not the worst i mean there's
superhero sidekick if you ask me right
um
get the [ __ ] kicked out of him in the
neighborhood i would have gone with bond
jehovah
that's why he's good shout out to
mcmuffin holy [ __ ]
damn this is [ __ ] crazy that's
bananas man
yeah all right and then uh the best the
best time ever going out door to door
though was
was i was with my mom and uh i knocked
on the door and this woman around my
mom's age answered the door and i
went through my whole spiel and uh she
was very polite
nodding and smiling listen to me and
then she just looks at my mom looks at
me
looks back at my mom she's like it's 11
o'clock
on a saturday morning wouldn't you
rather be at home
watching cartoons eating a bowl of
cereal to this to you
yeah she's turning you and i was like i
didn't know what to say my mom's like
well actually he he enjoys this this is
a volunteer work he has an opportunity
here to
to spread the goodness hey mike keep
your message out you're talking about
little sugar smacks can you be my mom
yeah
[ __ ] dude yeah at what age did you
uh get out of it so i was
uh i was you know i was it hands us a
pamphlet
yeah i locked the door now that i'm here
now that i got your attention
um so three meetings three meetings a
week
tuesday uh tuesday night was a was a
bible study at our house
so people would have to volunteer to
have parties this is like in high school
their house
off yeah all right did you learn to play
till i was 20 years old could no sports
no school dances
couldn't go over to house anybody's
house anybody that i want to school with
you look like you have a tear running
down you're right wait hold on a second
friday night you can't go stay at
[ __ ] railings house or whoever
no and get a pizza and go to games nope
nope i could only hang out with other
jehovah's witness kids
oh what'd you guys do it was in solitary
what'd you guys do just draw a hitler
mustache
publications work on your pitches with
each other yeah
damn dude yeah it was brutal but at the
same time i mean it it definitely sucked
but i was
i was raised that way so i didn't really
it's not like i had
holidays and they were taken away from
sure you didn't really know any
different yeah but you were showing up
to [ __ ] school and [ __ ] uh
you know me and kippy got two ninja
turtles in our hands
and [ __ ] pepperoni all over our face
we got [ __ ] ecto coolers for lunch
we're having a good time
we're talking about what we some titty
we saw in miami vites last night
aren't you like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
i mean i still watch scrambled porn too
i mean you know yeah he's not an animal
you try
you get away with as much as you can
yeah yeah you're still like getting
caught you would have been done oh yeah
come yeah total casper burns at the
stake my
uh but like you you remember in school
when a kid would have a birthday bring
in cupcakes pass around cupcakes sure i
had to leave the [ __ ] classroom and
go sit in the library by myself
until the birthday celebration was over
man pledge of allegiance
jobs witnesses are neutral so pledge of
allegiance i just had to [ __ ] stand
there with my hands at my side
first day of kindergarten looking like
[ __ ] kind of like
[ __ ]
somewhere else that ain't [ __ ]
happening damn
tell my old man that he can't my dad
pledges the legions of the flag every
morning
in the living room holy dude that's that
makes me sad
yeah yeah plus those [ __ ] homemade
cupcakes back in the day man when
somebody's mom would do them right now
that's what you're upset about oh they
were fantastic
you didn't get imaginary cupcakes and
that's what you're upset about
in this scenario you didn't get cupcakes
i'm saying i feel bad for smith that he
missed out on that chick
some of those moms back in the day they
knew what they were doing around the
oven
eat the cupcake anyway strike me down
jehovah it's too good would you
no i wouldn't but i would have kids you
know i like i said kids felt bad for me
i didn't get i didn't
i didn't get bullied because it was like
two yeah
yeah it was like take it easy on this
kid so kids would actually like
save me a little corner of their cupcake
or even like save them
or not to this day i still will just
like suck on the cupcake wrapper
because i that's what like that's what
my first
birthday cupcake ever was we're just
sucking the
chocolate crumbs out of a rapper oh
thanks for coming by
this guy just got out of shawshank and
for that day i was not even a jehovah's
witness
it was just like i was a regular guy i
just quit the grocery store i'm hanging
myself
[Laughter]
i just like the structure yeah
this is are you garbage not are you
suicidal
i'll rob's a bake sale though send me
back
dude what the [ __ ] man okay but what was
your first uh what was your first
christmas like though once you were out
uh it was horrible because i had you
know what he was doing
because i over the tree in the kitchen
the [ __ ] lights are in here
going it doesn't know what's up took him
two weeks to wrap the presents
that's got nothing
stockings are hung upside down holy [ __ ]
scared of the scrooge what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah stockings are full to come i can
finally jack off
oh yeah um so my yeah my first christmas
yeah three meetings a week you know none
of the [ __ ] that most kids
have and enjoy and then uh
when i'm seven when i was 17 my mom
died of a brain aneurysm so she
uh you know she was the one who was
about that decaffeinated
[ __ ] you gotta get we gotta warm me to
this [ __ ] dougie i know you're [ __ ]
your rope-a-doping is really good here
what the [ __ ]
rubble in the jungle i don't know what
the [ __ ] happening hey i'm from
connecticut by the way
strap in boys
this guy's bonkos you have a ride around
in a minivan on sunday morning oh man
this is a fun one [ __ ]
all right so your mom your mom passes
when you're 17. she does when i'm 17
and uh you know she was the one that was
she was the one driving the bus
yeah exactly yeah so my dad and i
uh we kept it up for another three years
because it's it's your world you know
it's something like
congregations like a family like when
you're in it you are taken care of
you know again similar to uh to hasidic
jews like
you know you're sick you they'll help
you pay your medical bills they'll watch
your kid for you they'll bring you meals
like you were taken care of
really but once you're out food
my mom my mom couldn't cook worth of
[ __ ] yeah so uh
like bland like everybody's like
i mean i had old parents so they ate
like they were they they ate like they
survived the depression you know
everything was boiled
so um a couple of slices some
[ __ ] [ __ ] nuts here the [ __ ]
but the one when you're uh when you're
out you're completely ostracized
so my dad and i even though technically
my mom's
out of the picture i have carp cart
blanche to do what i want uh
i have my freedom so to speak that was
my world you know for for [ __ ] 17
years
yeah did your brothers and your your
older siblings did they continue to
practice it
no so they all so my whole childhood was
watching them one after another
leave and watching my mom just
heartbroken every time because it was so
important to her would she still talk to
them and stuff like that would you still
see them
uh not written not so much not really
not really so even my own siblings once
they were out it was very
visits visits were very few and far
between jesus
so like you know the three of them left
one after another
and you know so left the church yeah
exactly so if i
left you know it would have been it was
like you knew it would have been like
the last man standing yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you know in the back of
your head you were like i'm not [ __ ]
doing this forever
i did yes yes so once i was once i was
like 15
and uh you know no parties no football
games
no dances what about going to the movies
with your friends not even dude i used
to feel so
guilty with his friend what are you
talking about
he had his first christmas at 21 movies
with his friends
kid didn't even have birthdays he
couldn't go to the movies the [ __ ] is a
movie
also i love how like john q america's
heads exploded
he saw footloose and was like what is
the documentary yeah yeah
no kevin bacon i'm out holy [ __ ]
yeah so your high school your high
school experience
oh it was awful there was none i can't
believe dude i'm amazed
i was waiting in the library when the
cupcakes came around what
do you think he's getting [ __ ] he's
getting a second base under the
bleachers
dude i used to feel so guilty about
masturbating because even masturbating
like
so frowned upon like you're still
ashamed for even having thoughts like
impure thoughts
but i just feel so guilty about
masturbating every time i did it
i used to put i would put five dollars
in a
[Laughter]
be able to buy those five acres in two
seconds
i'm sorry so five bucks in a jar to keep
no to donate to the church
because that's the entire organization
is funded by
donating by masturbation i
single-handedly built five [ __ ]
kingdom halls how do you think they got
guaranteed
yeah property you're welcome you
ingrates
um so i work you know i worked after
school jobs from the day i turned 16
my mom drove me into the middle of town
had no idea what we were doing i was
just running errands she pulled up in
the middle of town
main street she was like get out of the
car i'm going to pick you up in two
hours you better have a job by then
and i got a job at an office supply
store and i worked all through high
school
and like you said all of my [ __ ]
money
went into the jerk-off fund all of it
so i can't believe you're as normal as
how'd you land on five bucks too
it was it was like enough i got a
hundred it's going to be a long week
that's what i want to know how do you
put a nominal feeling that's a pretty
nice piece if i if i saw some scrambled
porn the night before i'd have to put in
a double shift
i'd only pay 1.50 i'll tell you that
right now so yeah
silver dollar five dollar dick started
edging from an early age
to save a couple bucks
that doesn't count big man down there
never pulled a trigger
damn dude yeah yeah so um
yeah um so when when uh your mom passes
your seven
passes i'm 17 my dad and i keep it up
for another three years even though we
both when she dies
he had been he had been sober for he had
been sober for about 30 years
he went completely off the rails i love
this i don't drink it hardcore kind of
like that
i like the romance of that i i did too
my first drink was at my
at after my mom's funeral i just got
[ __ ] hammered on mike's hard lemonade
and so my dad my dad and i was a second
he didn't even do that right wait a
minute
who's [ __ ] serving mike's drinking
like a girl
who's serving mike's hard eliminated a
funeral where was it what the [ __ ]
cancun what the [ __ ] i mean i was what
lights he had to go to the library
they got a swear knight if i'm being
honest
they gotta smear enough ice in the
casket
wait so when she passed did you know
like all right i'm going
like i can now obviously you're not
gonna like rip it right off but you're
like i'm gonna slowly start my descent
like i'm gonna go to
two services a week or whatever like
yeah i already i already
started questioning things when i was
like 15. you're still in high school
the next [ __ ] party that weekend i'm
going
movies candy [ __ ] all that stuff yeah
it was the bucket list i was the the
amount of [ __ ] guilt
that i had thinking that i had to
maintain it and keep doing it out of
respect for her
you know at all the amount of pressure
that i had put in
yeah yeah yeah to be the only one of her
kids that didn't you know
fall run by the wayside you know because
it was is it gonna burn in hell for all
eternity
yeah pretty much i mean dude she was
into it you know she was not
a casual member that's nuts i remember
being like seven in church being like
you [ __ ] people like i it didn't even
click then for me i was like i'm just
doing this until i don't have to anymore
i'm like you guys really all believe
this but my communion's over i'm out
yeah that's why i feel like i'm so good
at
coping with with boredom because i would
i would sit through
nine hours of church services a week
so like and one and two of them are at
at night so like tuesday
thursday you know you get half your
homework done then you gotta [ __ ]
suit up go to the kingdom hall you're
there for three hours
you gotta come home try to finish your
[ __ ] homework
and so i used to be so bored at the at
the meetings we had you know these
bibles that were this thick with like a
string bookmark
and i would just you know tune out the
second the the uh there was no priest
there was like
elders in the congregation and i would
tune out to the point that i would just
like take the book the bookmark string
and put it in my mouth
and just like swallow it all the way to
the all the way to the base of the shaft
basically and then just like slowly pull
it out like this is the
this is the [ __ ] that i resorted to
during the meetings you know it's like
guys
who fall in love with the torture yeah
i'm not gonna be a jova but i do have a
future in porno you know just deep
throat in this
bookmark um this kid's eating ruler
dude that's crazy oh and that's another
thing so i was doing that
also from an early age so everybody in
the congregation
it's like i said it's not just one
priest giving sermons to the
congregation
wow so my first sermon to the
congregation went out was when i was
eight years old
wasn't even tall enough to reach the
microphone at the at the podium
or just go pull out a literal soapbox my
down syndrome
just gets killed um and i did and i just
you know so i did that
all through my childhood teenage years
too and i was good at it i imagine
yeah and i had you know elders come up
to me being like hey you should you know
you could uh
they have these things called circuit
overseers which are basically like the
best
speakers of the elders they go around
they're basically homeless they're like
they're like uh religious troubadours so
to speak they basically just bounce
around from congregation and
congregation giving talks
and they were trying to groom me to to
be one of those guys
damn so that's why you know i never i
never had a pup
fear of public speaking because i was in
it yeah i was [ __ ]
you know and face rejection door-to-door
for [ __ ]
years exactly so yeah my dad and i were
both just huge [ __ ] booze bags for
three years
um and you know totally enabling each
other
and uh from 17 to 21 17 to 20.
yeah what about college did you take the
sats
i did yeah yeah good question uh 1080
1080 pretty good pretty very good 44
over four that's
not bad because i never again jehovah's
witnesses aren't allowed to go to
college so i never
i never thought yeah because again you
know you're mingling with world people
mingling with a guy who's licking
cupcakes
can't go to college what about phoenix
online
i'd rather be a jehovah
so he was connecticut amish dude
i had subwoofers in the back of my horse
and buggy
all right so 21. you're 20 years old
20 years old so i was able to convince
my dad to let me go
to art school with with the caveat
that i would commute from home so i was
going to try to live on
campus
so i i went to school of visual arts on
23rd street but i commuted from home
every day
okay it's like an hour and a half each
way so three hours round trip it was a
horrible it was you know it's not the
college experience it was [ __ ] awful
are you ever so i dropped out after two
years are you ever staying in the city
one night or two with like some friends
peep show or something nothing
i mean no i was still a good boy nope no
sex
nothing good looking i didn't do i
didn't lose my virginity so i was 21
so like half you know solid year after i
left
keep in mind you have you're he has like
no real no
no i mean come on it's his first day at
the big game
i rang your doorbell i got nothing
walked away what do you mean can i tell
you about the armageddon in my pants
good news folks
oh god you want to see the body of doug
nothing on that come on dude i'm [ __ ]
baffled
this put us through the ringer i had so
many questions
i have you ever ruined a pinball machine
i was gonna honestly have you ever old
navy performance
none other [ __ ] i was gonna say what do
you think about baby belle cheese
right looking like a fire boy over here
you say lake of fire
holy [ __ ] man oh my god
is your pop still with us is he still
alive no pass no
he oh he's still with us he's going to
be 90 in june
he's [ __ ] drinking and [ __ ] he's
like a madman up there i know he's
he's still boozing or did he get back on
the wagon he's still he's still boozing
he's still dead
ice cubes clicking around so tell us the
exodus of the church and then we're
going to ask you some mario garbage
questions
so now we're going to try to
have you ever seen a television have you
ever drank coffee
i think that's mormons as caught as the
cat i feel like i'm talking to kenneth
from 30 rock
[ __ ] guy
i was banging four teachers at a time i
drove a sirocco i don't know
man i worked at a cold stone i was
[ __ ] the owner i
dude yeah you talk about this on stage a
lot or no
i was just gonna say because i've never
been like i i have
no one's ever done everyone's ever like
you hear doug's bit about being the
joholt like you know what i mean right
you have other keystone bits that people
they as i'm as i'm sure you can tell
from this conversation
it's too much to do a couple of random
it's a lot to unpack
yeah yeah so my goal is to get out of
there yeah my goal before the pandemic
was to do
uh just an hour like a one-man show just
about that
wow um which i'm actually now turning
into a
into a podcast where i basically just
start out with you know
a story sure basically interview another
guest about
their childhood and all the [ __ ] that i
missed out on that's fantastic dude
it's such a it was a wild story let me
tell you it was [ __ ] awesome
it was dude fantastic [ __ ] roller
coasters and [ __ ] nerds and fun dips
man yeah yeah i got none of that
so uh i basically i did it for as long
as i [ __ ] could
you know that that three-year period
from 17 to 20 was just
[ __ ] miserable just yeah drunk and
[ __ ] sad
and uh and uh and you weren't supposed
to be drinking right
there no no so you and your dad were
drinking on the low don't tell
anybody we used to get hammered and then
do a [ __ ] coin toss to see who was
gonna drive to the kingdom hall
because we were both [ __ ] hamboned
that's pretty great
that's pretty rock star yeah and did you
say you were both ham bone
what a [ __ ] line that [ __ ] rule yo
kippy just lifted that
that's that's a hippie original t-bone
cut to cut that out
this kid's ham bone make a soup out of
him
ham bone i'm getting ham bone his
weekend for sure
i
god damn it i'm like a jehovah's witness
i can't do anything
goddamn heart medication uh huh
all right so the exit so i i i reached a
breaking point i couldn't do it anymore
i was commuting the [ __ ] sva every
day
i was like one of those coming typical
commuter [ __ ] getting drunk with
on tall boys on my ride home every day
let me see i'm trying to keep
interrupting you yeah if you guys were
breaking the rules
drinking right why was your dad busting
your balls about [ __ ] commuting to
school
if he was breaking the rules already too
uh
he was again it was it was it wasn't
just him it was me
thinking i was doing the right thing
like i found a little loophole in the
system
you know like i'm technically attending
classes but i'm not being immersed
in the college experience you know i'm
still kind of keeping myself
sheltered from the outside world other
kids like dude we're going to [ __ ]
spooners later you want to come and hang
out well that's a good thing about art
school it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
bunch of doors i was in an animation
program it was like 98 percent korean
girls
you know and i'm listening these guys
are getting lazy
[Laughter]
korean co-eds good night
it's not you know it's not uh it's not
it's not like there's no fracture
exactly
you want to [ __ ] university of miami
or something like that exactly right
so i just i reached a breaking point i i
sat my dad down one night after dinner
and i was like uh i was like dad
there's some nice boiled meat yeah two
cases of beer
what's your dad's drink it's after some
boiled ham and three cases you drink
some twisted tea in a boot
[Applause]
he was a canadian whiskey guy nice
wow i was anything guy yeah do you drink
now still
i don't i quit drinking about a year and
a half ago but i dude i
threw down [ __ ] hard for 20 years to
make it i remember you're boozing i
remember you losing at the clubs when we
were working together sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i always have a [ __ ] i definitely got
my fill it was something on the rocks it
was like a whiskey or something on my
rocks
yeah yeah he went right into it he just
went thousand yards
right he should have saw that he was
like yeah i did because i'm in the back
of my head i used to always think about
that because i'd be like i'm getting a
corona you'd be like give me a double
a double telly boy neat yeah i made up
for lost time for sure
so i uh i sat him down and i was like
dad i gotta tell you something and i you
know i'm already all
emotional i got tears streaming down my
face because i'm i'm worried that he
is gonna he's gonna be distraught you
know
and i was like i think i got to tell you
something and he goes i think i know
what it is
and i was like you do we're out of
mike's lemonade
[Laughter]
he's like you're gay you're not okay you
go to art school
so it's like i gotta tell you something
he's like i think i know what it is and
i was like you do he's like
you don't want to do this anymore and i
was like how did you know he's like
[ __ ] i don't want to do this anymore
either you've been doing that still doug
jesus
christ i haven't done that [ __ ] in years
wait you still been going
he's chopping up coke he's got a four
logo
live it up you [ __ ] [ __ ] face tattoo
okay so it was it to to this day it's
the closest
moment my dad and i have ever seen that
big embrace huge
just the most relief i've ever felt in
my entire life just knowing that we were
on the same page
like all right we don't have to do this
anymore we did this for three years
thinking it was the right thing but
we're gonna
[ __ ] blow our brains out if we keep
this up
so uh we just kind of stopped going to
meetings
when they started going to aaa meetings
listen it meets in a church when they
call them they don't let you walk away
right they they
they kept after us for a little while
wow um but
you know it we it wasn't like a hard and
fast line drawn in the sand like we're
[ __ ] you we're done with this we
we both we kind of just kind of tapered
off yeah
yeah less and less meetings and they
finally
i don't think anybody could blame us you
know what i mean because my mom was so
in it and they knew that they knew that
our
you know they saw us showing up at the
kingdom all hammered for the last three
years so they weren't you know they
weren't
sure oh they knew you were this captain
under wraps yeah they knew we were just
going through the motions
so nobody was really that surprised you
know what i mean what was the first
thing you did like when
when the i know you said it wasn't hard
and fast but like
in your head it is in your head it's
like oh my god i don't have to do this
anymore
like what's the first first thing i mean
how much time we got left because
the floor is yours so one of my one
eternity in hell apparently
yeah so take your time
you can kick me out of here but watch
your ass
i'll keep knocking so one of my friends
in the congregation who i'm still
friends with the building's gonna get
pissed we let them in
yeah once you leave that door yeah you
don't go knocking on me yeah i'm gonna
have to walk about the front the doorman
is gonna be like [ __ ] kippy
who let the jehovah's witness in this
kid tried to flip me on the way in
hey hector have you heard the good news
i love it you're catching on quick
i love how you use the phrase flippin
that's that's real bon jovi that's not
the old testament
what is that [ __ ] uh joe pesci to the
romans hey what you want to do is flip
them come on
i'm ready to walk out that was gold
it was a little it was a little birdie
t-bone where are you at over here
dude i thought that was gonna be a
show-stopper
i thought the lights were going to pop
out i did stop it just the wrong way
doug just laughed to be nice it's like
you mixed up
five genres of nine movies i didn't know
what was going on this guy's all done
i still don't know what movies are so
i'm just taking your word for it who's
that joe pesci who the [ __ ] is joe
yeah is that like a kinetic
all right all right all right all right
back at it holy [ __ ]
so one so one of my buddies in the
congregation uh
big shout out to matt still still one of
my best buddies maddie
he uh he he was he kind of had his
he kind of had his toe dipped in the
water of the outside world from a much
earlier
dude i can't believe we had none he was
coming like so what do you know about
doug where's brian would do jesus
christ i only know the one story i know
the one doug smith story that we haven't
even gotten it's not even close
yeah yeah that's i mean my my heathen
life is a completely separate chunk
i can't wait to hear about you going on
rum spring
[ __ ] doug smith straight to hell tour
well this is it this is where we're
getting to
all right so my my buddy matt he he'd
been working uh
he had been working in the restaurant
business since he was like 15 like
started out as like a bar back
and he was always a good cook though and
so he he wanted to work his way up in
the culinary world
so he worked at various restaurants in
westchester uh
he was a manager at once and he was like
he i always kind of looked up to him
because he was
he was successfully living a double life
you know what i mean like he was
drinking doing coke
he was banging the [ __ ] manager of
this restaurant this woman who was
married with three kids like banging her
in her office like here's a paper supply
store or something like that
yes so i [ __ ] idolize this dude i was
like all right if he can do it maybe if
i finally get the balls you know
so then when i finally left uh when i
left jehovah's witnesses he was living
in san diego
i needed to get the [ __ ] out of my
parents house i need to get out of the
congregation i just needed to get
away you know so he was like come out to
san diego it's beautiful here we live
two blocks from pacific beach
come check it out if you want to move in
with us he was living with another
guy that he met uh uh you're welcome to
so i go out there
um he picks me up from the airport he's
acting super squirrely and i was like
what's going on dude he's like i gotta i
gotta ounce a coke in my glove box
jesus he's like i'm doing a little
dealing on the side and i realized i had
never you know i just to pick you from
the airport
i was just like thrown to the wolves
dude i had never seen cocaine
before like i hadn't seen him in like he
had been living out there for like a
year so i had no idea how the extent to
which he went off the rails you know
so right i get
[Laughter]
got on the rails so i get to their
apartment
and it is the worst squalor i've ever
seen in my life it's like it's like a
it's it looks like uh you know how like
west coast apartment complexes are it's
like
a single story kind of horseshoe shaped
complex wall-to-wall carpeting like
did the the sink was the sink was just
loaded with dishes
flies everywhere like thick shag carpet
in the living room was covered in like
weed
just you know like beer cans with the
beer
beer can bong things littered around it
was bong water
it was disgusting [ __ ] squalor their
electricity had gotten shut off because
they hadn't paid the electric bill
at least a little bit of cash yeah yeah
let the product do the talking right
[Laughter]
you got the salesman experience so uh
as soon as i get there they're like what
do you think this play is a real
[ __ ] right and i was like it's yeah
it's kind of gross they're like yeah
we're gonna we're gonna set it on fire
and collect renters insurance it was
like a
it was like a running joke all week we
just got a 25
000 uh renters insurance policy and it
was you know we were laughing about it
all week
and uh well you got a guy in the biz
your dad could have [ __ ] helped you
out too a little bit right
yeah so uh it was it was a great week
because you know just
boozing i wasn't i didn't do coke but i
smoked weed for the first time out of a
sprite can
i felt like a [ __ ] shotgun blast of
the lungs you know but i was like hooked
on weed immediately
so i was just getting high as [ __ ] every
day going training day
yeah going to the beach every day just
not what you know it's what you can
prove dog
talking about going to see the three
wise men
so uh so his roommate jc
uh he's also sounds respectable yeah
the oh by by the way the first i know of
this guy i walk in
and on their coffee table there's like
three polaroids
of like a of a huge dick and i was like
what are these he's like that's
jc that's jc my roommate and i flip over
the polaroid and a phone number is
written on the back of the polaroid
and matt was like yeah jc likes to go to
bars and slip these in women's purses
that was his pickup strategy don't talk
to a girl
take a polaroid of your dick write your
phone number on the back and slip it in
a woman's purse
holy
so i see this dude's dick before he even
emerges from the room so you know he's
already got
a reputation for good things so
uh your first taste of the outside world
was exactly what your mom thought it was
yeah
yeah yeah absolutely yeah yeah it was
yeah
that's right so it's a great week i'm
like this is paradise you know i'm
hanging out on the beach getting
plastered every day smoking weed you
know they're working during the day we
hang out at night
and then finally the day before i'm
supposed to go home
i'm sitting on the couch one morning
eating cereal watching tv
and the front door swings open and jc is
standing there in a suit he's like
backlit from i remember just like seeing
his silhouette
and he's like backlit from the sun and
he's holding the gas tank from his
motorcycle
oh my god like like you know holding it
like a football
and he walks in he walks in through the
kitchen i was like what's what's going
on man he's like pack your [ __ ] man it's
going down and i was like hey
all right he's like i'm serious man i'm
torching this place and i was like
what he's like i'm serious man pack your
[ __ ] it's going down
and i'm sitting there and i watch him
walk over
keep in mind the electricity is shut off
they're going by candlelight for a
full [ __ ] week i watched this dude
douse
a [ __ ] laundry basket and gasoline
shove it into the closet and he's like
dude pat your [ __ ] i'm doing it it's
going down so i pack my stuff
and then i'm like all right hold on i
don't i don't want to be an accomplice
here but i also don't want it to be
obvious that there's arson going on
right
so my genius idea i grab a roll of
toilet paper and like a fuse
i just toilet paper the whole inside of
the apartment because i'm thinking
all right if they're gonna torch this
place they might as well do it right
you know so i toilet paper the whole
inside of the
uh apartment and then right before he
strikes the match i'm like
this probably isn't a good idea because
if this doesn't burn it's gonna be
pretty
it's gonna be pretty suspicious you know
so i quickly like take it down
and he [ __ ] strikes a match tosses in
the laundry basket
i hop on the [ __ ] beach cruiser with
my duffel bag and i'm riding out to the
beach
and my heart is pounding out of my chest
i'm just hey i'm hanging on the beach
and sure enough within 10 minutes
just sirens galore and
i call matt um and i was like
i was like dude jc jc did it
i didn't want to like say what you know
over the phone was like jc did it
and it was like kind of wish you weren't
telling us yeah right
dump this episode jesus what's the
statue of limitations in california i
don't know
um so there was just like a silence on
the phone i didn't need to elaborate at
all he's like all right i'll be there in
20 minutes
and uh so there's some sounds
and i i was like i want to see what the
what the damage is here i want to ever
return to the scene of the crime
so i i hop on the on the beach cruise
and i go as as close as i can to see
without actually getting spotted keep in
mind nobody knows i'm there you know i
can't get pinched for anything
for anything there's a kid learns quick
i ain't going back grabbed a couple of
jc's polaroids and i got the hell out of
it
[Laughter]
something to remember so i
i pedal over there and sure enough
there's a hole in the roof like the
the width of this room you know like a
just
a huge hole in the roof and there's
there's like three fire trucks
ambulance cop cars they could have
killed the entire con
park but luckily they they put it out
and uh matt uh has to like give this
whole
sob story to the to the cops and
basically
they use that they were like listen we
we uh our electricity went out we were
going by candlelight all week
one of the candles must have tipped over
and that was another thing that jc did
he took a stool
and he tipped it over right next to the
laundry basket with like a couple of
candles near there that i guess
didn't burn so their whole story of
a candle tipping over and igniting the
place [ __ ] worked
even though they they doused the thing
with gasoline arson police didn't
suspect a thing and they got [ __ ] 25
grand
and they blew it in a matter of two
months with trips to vegas
on like cocaine and hookers so obviously
i never moved to san diego
holy [ __ ] can you say that publicly the
place i was going
first and last name i know i don't know
this was like 15 years ago
that was 100 years ago what are you
talking about
this was in cincinnati that's a hell of
a screenplay
you're out there doug while you were in
hollywood
holy [ __ ] yeah wow so
that was uh that yeah that was my room
first weekend
and then so you went back so you go you
go back home
it's hot there did you have a power
wheels growing up
[Laughter]
so it was a no to the henna tattoo right
holy [ __ ] all right let's run through a
couple as it is are you garbage we got
to
i don't i did tell that story you
remember uh
mark norman and matt ruby had a podcast
like 10 years ago
we're all friends here i remember
telling that on that and j
j welch you guys know yeah yeah he was a
lawyer and he came up to me afterward
he's like you better find out what the
statue of limitations is before you keep
telling that story
and then i thought i think i hope well
done jesus
i thought about googling it we'll put
our lawyers on it
i'm just gonna google it but i'm not
allowed to touch computers what are you
gonna do
let's just say if any listeners work in
the san diego pd be cool
hold on we'll send you a couple of
[ __ ] hoodies yeah i got a deck of
cards if you'll play ball
before we get to the questions let me
give out the street address
[Laughter]
this guy's all over the [ __ ] place
dude you're [ __ ]
bonkers man
and answer your question yes i had power
wheels really no
i did i mean i could still get toys it
just couldn't be on a
special occasion oh so did you have like
a gi joes and growing up and
transformers uh i did yeah i had a
couple of transformers
were you allowed to watch tv did you say
i was but you know like no
mtv you know no music videos
i wasn't allowed to watch ren and stimpy
and now i know why i wouldn't let my kid
watch ren and stimpy it's
very edgy yeah it's very
i haven't watched it i had to go back
and put some new freshwater gruesome
homoeroticism you know is it yeah it's
right
yeah it was way ahead of it it's a
raunchy show
so yeah i was allowed to watch tv my mom
i was allowed to buy music my mom
read the liner notes of every cd that i
brought home and if there was any curse
words straight in the garbage
damn uh [ __ ] he got the receipt sam
goody's down the block well you can't go
back
turn it i was a big rap fan as a
teenager my mom
found all my rap cds when i was away one
weekend like 400
worth of rap cds made me throw all of
them out damn
yeah so you know i was allowed to
live you know live a somewhat secular
life but with you know
parameters yeah yeah yeah shortly
yeah this all culminates to that weekend
in san diego oh holy
[ __ ] that's not an argument against
organized religion i don't know what it
is
jesus christ yeah cool
i got one for you now yeah what about
now what's the situation now
what was your wife what she's normal she
normal
uh yeah yeah she grew up um
did she know any of this yeah but she
had no idea the extent of this when we
got together
you know she was uh i was i was every
time you have sex he puts a 20 in a
[ __ ]
shoebox
[Laughter]
where's my nest egg i'm building
churches over here yeah every time he
comes he starts bawling his eyes
and wants a mike's hard lemonade i don't
know what to do with this kid
wow oh okay i was only three years out
when we got together
so you know i've been in you know you
say i seem like a normal guy i've been
in
therapy for the last 12 years you know
lots of anger lots of resentment
lots of feelings of of you know feeling
like i've lost out on a lot of time
you know well it's a [ __ ] big man
rubbing it in it doesn't help
no you're telling me you never had nerd
wrong i'm sorry
you're not gonna sit here tell me you
don't eat peeps
wait so you never had stuffed crust
pizza
you never felt a boob in a roller
skating party
no ah i was the best
i'm sorry i'm just i'm so shocked seven
minutes in heaven was just me alone
jerking off
and 55 bucks like other people like
cupcakes
i don't even know what's all right now
that's more than you guys were
bargaining no that's [ __ ]
fantastic i wish it was sweeps week
that's great
if i can put this out tonight at
midnight i mean
have you ever bought pre-cut denim jeans
[Laughter]
what about now what's this it now tv
with the whole the whole nine yards
right
yeah yeah i mean you know you let the
kids your kid has birthdays you do
christmas you do all that stuff that's
like that's the great thing about having
a kid is i'm able to kind of
watch him enjoy all the [ __ ] that i
wasn't allowed to have
and it's it's you know it doesn't make
up for that but it's it's nice to be
able to
to provide it and the thought of putting
him through that is [ __ ]
crazy you know the thought of of putting
of oh if you go to church
yeah like it's it's [ __ ] mind-blowing
jesus so as great as it is to have a kid
that i can
you know let him experience that [ __ ]
it's it's magnified
even more how [ __ ] up it was that my
parents
did that sure so man
anyway
what's the name of that album again
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] let's just do some of this to
some of the staples net for now all
right
so you got 1080 was the sats yup
do you have a passport i do have a
passport how old were you when you got
that
nine for like missions or vacations no
no we went to england when i was nine
for vacation all right that's not too
much what'd you do over there
saw a bunch of [ __ ] castles i said
some scones and clotted cream
yeah my grandma uh went to boarding
school there so
like we uh we visited the town she went
to boarding school it was a horror you
know when you're nine years old
english countryside is not the most
thrilling trip no not at all well that's
nothing better than your house in
connecticut though
yeah a little bit more at least a change
of scenery you said your mom and your
dad both came from a little bit of
scratch
yep and nobody and their extended family
like their parents were jehovah's
witnesses right
what was the interaction with them like
what would happen when like your mom's
parents
would have they thought she was [ __ ]
crazy so
what happened when i was like hey it's
thanksgiving and you're bringing the
family over for thanksgiving
no i mean they they they knew yeah she
couldn't do that yeah but my
my grandfather and my aunt on my mom's
side would
constantly busting her balls about it
you know they they thought she was out
of her [ __ ] mind
when did you have your first first
thanksgiving dinner
uh also when i was when i was 21.
yeah birthday like i said a question and
the answer is always well when i was 21
he's like
my first my first birthday that i
celebrated was my 21st birthday
and uh it was i didn't you know i still
didn't have a lot of friends
outside of the jehovah's witness
community so it was like my siblings
some of their friends i got [ __ ]
hamboned within
[Laughter]
20 you know it was all like pregame at
the house we'll go out to a bar
you know it's a celebration i didn't
even make it to the bar dude i woke up
face down on the living room floor bunch
of cups with half my head shaved
a pierced ear nice and uh
dicks drawn all over my forehead there
you go yeah
that was my first birthday what's the uh
[Laughter]
what's the situation in the house now um
what's the snack situation over there
snack situation i don't even know where
to go
i feel like we have to ask the questions
i mean your garbage let me help you out
let me help you out i had a lava lamp my
son has a lava lamp now
now oh he's fine he keeps his bong under
the bed
zeppelin
like i said i want him to have all the
[ __ ] that i did normally yeah
sure you keep the butter on the counter
in the fridge
butter in the fridge is it butter is it
margarine butter
okay yeah all right respectable do you
churn it yourself
uh well what kind of car you got uh a
uh honda civic not too bad i got 2018
leased
not bad though what should be coming up
pretty soon too it's 2021.
did you get a five year lease three so
you should be getting ready to get a new
and it is
banged up i am really dreading returning
that thing really yeah it's tough to
have one in new york right now
it's [ __ ] crumpled yeah it's bad it
looks bad what's in the cup holder
currently of your car
a cup holder currently of my car uh
nothing but i always i'm surprised i
didn't have it today i always have a
[ __ ] uh thermos mug of coffee on me
at all times
i mean if you're worried about returning
a car you can always call jc and steiner
get the boys back together
i'm gonna need a pipe bomb and
yup for one more old boy
i literally have that written down were
you a pop pop-tarts or
strudel family strudel unfortunately
really
yeah because for some reason my mom
thought strew strudel was uh
more whole it was healthier did she let
you put the icing on there
yeah that's pretty good yeah when was
the last time you slept on a blow-up
mattress
uh when i first moved to new york with
with matt the san diego buddy former
j-dub
and uh we lived on orchard street
together for a couple of months that's
not a bad spot though
it's all right any posters on the wall
when you were a kid
yes so i uh
do you guys know who cheryl ladd is yeah
do you really
yeah of course who is it so share cheryl
ladd replaced farrah fawcett
on charlie's angels i've always had a
thing for
older women for some reason it's it's
kind of a strange
thing you're [ __ ] up i am [ __ ] up
yeah my wife is eight and a half years
older than me
nice um so my i i remember seeing
uh charlie's angels as a teenager and
just you know
seeing cheryl lad and just being like
this is this is my dream woman
so i spent two two solid years as a
teenager bidding on ebay
on cheryl add posters and autographed
eight by tens
and i basically had like a cheryl lad
shrine
in my room and i also in addition to
that i had uh
yeah i had a bunch of like band posters
i wanted david lee roth
debbie harry he likes smashing pumpkins
but you're 38 you're watching charlie's
angels i'm throwing that up
what's going on with that charlie's
angel's re-runs on on tv land oh
all right yeah give it to you i was a
big heather thomas guy from the fall guy
not heather locklear heather thomas also
a big thomas muffins guy
and we're back i like a cinnamon raisin
every once in a while i'm not gonna lie
to you
huh holy [ __ ]
i mean trash i don't know right i don't
think
i think this one's inconclusive you
can't call that trash
the name of this episode is are you
traumatized
i can't call trash i mean he's not
classy he ain't classy
right i mean i got i definitely still
got some connecticut
snobbery in me for sure yeah yeah in
what sense do you think
he does arsons and boat shoes yeah what
are you talking about torture
i mean that wasn't him he was in a bad
situation
he did the toilet paper he got it and
then pulled it off the walls
pretty smart i did i repented for myself
yeah yeah yeah i don't know you call it
i can't call
try i don't know this guy's bonko's for
sure
are you bonkers
is it garbage i don't know you said you
think you're garbage
i mean i i do like engaging a lot of
public urination
was there responsible for the stench in
the city
do i have a garage at the house house
yeah yep is there a fridge in there
no no garage fridge um
my dad was a gun collector made his own
bullets
that's crafty i think we can stop there
you're [ __ ] trash
holy [ __ ] doug smith yeah this has been
a
[ __ ] bananas one crazy go and take a
shower
call my mom and thank you for all the
birthday cakes
i'll never break her balls again i'll
tell you that that's nuts man
holy [ __ ] are you garbage man
[ __ ] good that's been the most
gripping episode we've had it's [ __ ]
something else written and directed by
quentin tarantino
from dusk till doug that's
[ __ ] up button it up you got anything
you want the folks out there to know
uh i'm okay
where's your next felony
[Laughter]
uh staying at a stop and shop on 21st
street on thursday
oh [ __ ] you got the podcast coming out
podcast coming out stay tuned for that
um
no yeah no real uh no real gigs coming
up
follow me on sure social medias at who
doug smith
and um yeah that's it absolutely
fantastic
thank you guys for having me very funny
thank you for being so open and honest
this was [ __ ] unbelievable
i'm sorry i was still dumbfounded i was
just [ __ ] wrapped up in it man
that was [ __ ] something else what do
you got for him uh guys thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure to
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube patreon.com
and i'm at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media also follow the pod is at
ru garbage
on twitter and uh instagram yes check it
out
at each foley on ice on twitter and
foleygrams on instagram t-bone got
anything
uh toby.mcmullen on instagram yeah
that's right buddy we love you guys
we'll see you next week
peace
[Music]
that was holy dude hold on there kids
real quick before you go taking off on
your skateboards or your
rollerblades your rollerblades your
convertible cars wherever you're off to
want to talk real quick one more time
about the stereo app kippy and i are on
there every thursday
night at nine o'clock answering your
questions fantastic app
all kinds of amazing shows whether you
have an android or an iphone you can
download
get it on your phone for free yeah guys
it's an easy way for you to interact
with us and we interact with you
it gives you a different vibe of the
show it's a live stream you
you it's every every thursday nine
o'clock we're having a good time baby
i might i might stutter a little bit i
might have been drinking now but i'll
definitely be drinking on thursday party
starts early at the ryan
9 pm we'll see you there baby it's a
good time peace